[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator tv
and broadcast on thursday march 3rd i'm
kate andrews the spectators economics
editor and your host this week
on this week's show
the russian invasion of ukraine
continues putin's forces are struggling
to take key ukrainian cities but they
are making inroads the west has united
in punishing russia with crippling
economic sanctions we'll make sure
you're across everything that's
happening
security expert dimitri alperovich a
military strategy expert sir lawrence
friedman will join us to explain what's
happening on the battlefield is there
any possibility of a kremlin coup
the financier and sanctions campaigner
bill browder will explain what more the
west can do are the sanctions really
working
freddie gray our deputy editor is in
ukraine what's going on on the ground
douglas murray our associate editor says
the american right has found itself in a
muddle over putin why have some of them
been chanting the dictator's name
and we'll finish on british politics
giving you the latest from westminster
with katie balls and james forsyth
before we get going a very special thank
you to canaccord community wealth
management who are sponsoring the week
in 60 minutes can accord our experienced
wealth planners and investment managers
who go above and beyond to offer you
support and guidance just visit candu
wealth dot com to find out more
and remember to subscribe to our youtube
channel too click the red subscribe
button at the bottom of this video and
tap the bell icon to make sure you never
miss an episode
we're now a week into the russian
invasion of ukraine putin's forces have
taken swaths of land in the south of the
country but are struggling to get
control of ukraine's two biggest cities
including its capital kiev to talk
through exactly what's been happening
and why putin's invasion isn't going
quite according to his plan i'm joined
by dimitri alperovich a security expert
and chairman of the silverado policy
accelerator think tank in washington dc
and sir lawrence friedman one of
britain's top military strategy experts
and a professor at king's college london
who sat on the chillcott inquiry into
the iraq war
lawrence could you start by briefly
talking us through what's happened over
the past several days in ukraine and
what is the state of the russian
invasion at the moment
well
in its original form it's stalled
and i would say in some respects failed
uh in that the aim was to move quickly
into
at least
kiev and
garcia and
take the cities and
execute regime change and that just
hasn't happened um i think it's taken a
rather unpleasant turn
um because
because it's stool
um
and because of the difficulties of urban
warfare
uh which is taking place and it's not as
if they've given up completely on that
uh but they've uh the russians have
resorted
um to much more brutal tactics uh
with uh strikes into into the city
centers
this could be seen as softening up um
but i think it's
in a way also a sort of form of siege to
make life miserable for the people there
a couple with shortages of
and medicines
i don't think
this will help russia in the end i think
the most important thing that's happened
over the last few days is the
mobilization of ukraine
that made what to me always seemed
likely uh
a hopeless prospect for the for the
russians if they ever try to occupy and
control
ukraine uh but that's made it even even
harder and so
but it also means that the war will go
on longer
demetrius lawrence suggests there the
invasion isn't going according to
putin's plan he's increasingly turning
to more aggressive measures dropping
heavy artillery against citizen areas in
major ukrainian cities
what do you make of the change in his
plans
well what was most puzzling is that in
an initial four to five days of the
conflict they really did not fight like
they trained to fight
russian military is a heavy artillery
military uh relying on on standoff
weaponry uh heavy weapons like
missile strikes and
multiple launch rocket systems uh to
accomplish the objectives they did not
use any of that in fact their even their
tactical bomber aviation was sitting on
russian airfields uh virtually
completely unused in those initial days
because i think they had a completely
mistaken assumption that they could just
roll into kiev with uh you know a 10
column armored vehicle
reconnaissance
company and and take it over
that
turned out to be disastrous for them and
they've now reverted to the mean which
is uh leveling cities like they had done
in chechnya with grozny like they had
done in syria and aleppo we're seeing
indiscriminate targeting inaccurate
targeting into the centers of kharkiv
into the centers of kiev in other cities
that is how they fight that is their
doctrine and uh unfortunately they're
now going to use overwhelming force and
kill a lot of civilians to accomplish
their objectives
lawrence will a bombardment of ukraine
similar to what we saw the russians do
to syria eight years ago and in grozny
and chechnya in 1999 actually work
um
well i mean that they can execute
bombardment so
it's much easier to to fire off
artillery from a distance than to uh
than to try to enter a city i i'm not
sure
it's harder to do i mean the point is
about aleppo say um
the aim was to depopulate areas to push
people out
and they had the syrian
infantry uh since doing the the work on
the ground for them
they haven't done anything like this for
in terms of ground operations for a long
time which is one reason why
they may not have quite captured what
they needed to do and dmitry said
but i don't think just bombarding will
work for them even in grazny they still
had to enter the city
and you can still fight amongst rubble
uh so it does it it it
it doesn't solve problems and you know
to the extent they're actually attacking
real targets rather than just
indiscriminate it really doesn't make a
lot of difference if you if you knock
out an administrative building
so it's not clear whether there's a
serious strategy behind this or it's the
sort of thing we do when when we when
we're frustrated and uh and we're trying
to work out how to move this forward and
we're sort of hoping that the ukrainians
uh might concede us a bit in in the
cease-fire talks so i'm not quite sure
if there's a clear end game in mind with
all of this at the moment
uh dimitri is there any chance that the
complete takeover of ukraine by russia
is now gone or is that still a very real
possibility
well they can certainly take it and and
by the way they have made a lot of
progress in the south they took the city
of hersone which is a pretty big city
uh in in the last 24 hours they've
surrounded mariopol another huge city in
the south uh they're making progress
towards the north and zaparogia and
towards the neapro
so they're making progress their
offensive uh is encountering much more
resistance in the northeast um where i
think they expected a much easier time
given that it's mostly pro uh
russian-speaking population that they
assume would be pro-russian um and of
course uh from the west they they are um
in the key of suburbs uh fighting
fighting there's a pretty aggressive
fighting there um so uh i think it's
misleading to to to say that they they
haven't made any progress um it's been
slower than they expected for sure and
they're taking more casualties um than
they thought they would uh but um
steadily but surely they're taking
progress and and they have the forces to
do so the big question of course is what
happens next you can take the cities you
can decimate ukrainian military units
with air strikes and artillery
and then surround them with your ground
invasion forces but then what
and
as lawrence pointed out the the
ukrainian population is mobilizing i
know a lot of people um that are sort of
just regular people without any military
backing that are going off to fight
kissing their kids for the last time and
uh
you know getting a rifle um to go fight
the russians so this this can turn into
a very nasty insurgency for them it
seems like it already is
um and holding the country afterwards i
think is is going to be
an extraordinarily
challenging for them i mean i'd go
further i think it's impossible i just
don't think they've got the numbers to
hold a country i mean they're certainly
making progress in the south uh the
forces coming in from crimea
uh and they can push forward but you
know this is a very large country
and
you need you know if you just think of
the challenges that the russians faced
in afghanistan or even in chechnya that
the americans faced in iraq and
afghanistan if you have a serious
insurgency you need far more troops than
over a long period than they can really
spare for this so i think that in that
sense i think that
they would they will fail
um
the question is i suppose what
bargaining position they put themselves
into
uh as you uh on the assumption at some
point there will have to be a negotiated
conclusion
lawrence we saw reports in the times
this week that some 400 mercenaries on
the orders of moscow were sent into kiev
to hunt down zielenski the ukrainian
president
he has become a source of inspiration
for the ukrainian people and frankly for
many people throughout the world but
will he have to decide whether or not to
leave kiev at some point soon
well the the assumption to start with
the americans were urging this
is he needed to move out quite sharply
um
you know either go to levi's or to form
a government in exile even and he made
the decision to stay which i think
turned out to be the right decision in
terms of uh the resistance being posed
by by ukraine and it's interesting the
the the the qualities of leadership that
can be shown especially by somebody who
knows to find words and deliver them i
mean does really help being an actor in
in these circumstances and the
comparison with putin
you know with his long tables and
uh
scared of human contact
and sort of wooden and odd phrases is
quite striking um
but the issue could arise i mean the
issue could certainly arise uh and you
presume they will have thought about
that but i mean he's not the only one
there's quite a number of senior
ukrainian politicians holed up
in kiev and at the moment they're saying
they'll stay whether they'll
see that if russians genuinely are
pouring into the center
uh and there's a means of escape we we
don't know i think the worst thing would
be for zielinski to be captured by the
russians i think that would be a very
bad turn of events
and dmitry to what extent is this
resistance making a big difference to
the outcome of the invasion that we've
seen so far
well i don't think unfortunately it'll
make much of a difference to the russian
taking critical objectives like
potentially taking kiev it will slow
them down it will
cause them to take more casualties
unfortunately will also take them make
them to
be much more brutal in their tactics uh
you know you have to appreciate the the
psychological of this cannot be
underestimated uh ukraine in particular
eastern ukraine and southern ukraine
looks a lot like russia
lots of people speak russian if you see
sort of a babushka on a street it looks
like the soldier's grandmother so
psychologically i think it's been very
difficult for the russians to fight this
war in the initial stages because
they've not been prepared in fact it
appears that most of the troops haven't
even been told that they're going to
invade ukraine until the very last
moment
there's been no realistic pretax they
don't understand why they're there
and why they're shooting at people that
look just like their family however i
think that's starting to change now as
they're taking severe casualties
inevitably that hardens people and
they're becoming much more ruthless
you've seen some horrible war crime
videos come out of them just shooting up
civilians um and again indiscriminate
targeting
and and hitting um universities hitting
schools um
targeting hospitals um so i think
they're just gonna get more and more
brutal and again they can take their
objectives they did so obviously in
syria they did so in chechnya
but
the question is can they hold them
and lawrence you were saying before that
you weren't convinced that russia could
actually stage a long-term occupation is
there any way that you think that this
invasion could still seem like a success
for putin
well um
i mean it depends on the outcome uh i
don't think it won't achieve a success
in the sense there'll be a puppet regime
because no no regime that isn't backed
by occupation forces will be seen as
legitimate and could cut remember this
is a country that's twice seen
moderately pro-russian presidents
overturned by popular movements because
they were believed to be rigging
elections so i don't think
um in that sense they they can succeed
uh
it's very difficult to judge what
success looks like i mean if if putin
really believes this is a country run by
drug addicts and nazis then you can say
well look there's no drug addicts and
nazis if you're saying that this is a
country that's trying to get nuclear
weapons say no one you know we won't get
nuclear weapons um so you you you can
the way that it's been phrased as a
special operation and so on makes it
actually hard to know how how you
present the result back back home
i think in practice
it's going to be difficult to have an
agreement that doesn't recognize
ukraine as an independent state
so what you're then talking about is
finding things that you can do
that seem to acknowledge um some of
russian's russian concerns perhaps uh
confirm the annexation of crimea and so
on i think a peace deal is possible but
it's actually quite difficult at the
moment
and it won't become easier just because
uh you you've er you you've caused
you've committed more crimes and and
made the situation in in
ukrainian cities more horrific in some
ways it becomes harder
dimitri what do you make of that
i completely agree i think uh the
atrocities that they're committing have
turned virtually all ukrainians except
those are still collaborating around the
pay of the
uh russians uh into enemies for them and
i think that hardened resolve
will stay for a very long time
and
it's going to be very very difficult for
them to run an occupation now having
said that
i don't think we should underestimate
russia's counterinsurgency capabilities
if you look at what they did in chechnya
with extreme brutality with torture with
war crimes they have
largely pacified their area we haven't
seen terrorist attacks in in chechnya in
a very long time and they've done it
actually rather quickly um they they
started the second chechen war in 1999
towards the later uh uh uh of of the
year to the second part of the year and
um
largely completed their
counter-terrorism operations there by
about 2004-2005 so within five or six
years they've managed to pacify it and
uh there's just an incredible article
that i read uh back in 2015 where uh the
journalist was interviewing a chechen
jihadist in istanbul who was on the way
to syria that just highlights the the
the uh
russian victories in chechnya because
they were asking this person why are you
going to syria to fight the americans in
assad when you can be in chechnya
fighting the russians and he said it's
literally safer for me to be in syria
because in
chechnya you know you hold up in the
mountains you have to come down from the
mountains into the villages to get
supplies and everyone has mobile phones
they'll immediately call the russians on
you because they would fear that if they
don't and the russians ever find out
they'll massacre the whole village
that's how the russians fight
insurgencies extremely brutal committing
war crimes
but
they're able to achieve results in many
of these cases
obviously failed in afghanistan but did
work in chechnya
so um we'll see if they're going to
resort to these horrendous tactics in
ukraine to try to keep the
population pacified i do think that at
this point putin must be
rethinking uh his initial
assumptions about this this conflict um
he really did i think i think that he
was going to be treated as liberator and
that the ukrainian forces would just
melt away and and go home
um
having seen the resistance that he's
encountering
and thinking about the long-term cost of
occupations here occupation here he may
be
thinking that he could pressure zelinski
perhaps with threat of death
to try to get some concessions i think
the minimum bar for him would be for
ukraine to recognize crimea's russian
for ukraine to uh forever abandon its
pursuit of nato and eu membership and
some sort of agreement on
demilitarization and a minimum no more
weapons supplies from from nato i don't
think that zolonski would take that deal
even under threat of death uh but uh
putin may be trying to go for that
uh for that for that strategy
uh lawrence last question to you you
wrote this week it is now as likely that
there will be a regime change in moscow
as in kiev
what would a coup in moscow look like
oh i don't know i mean
all i mean i think as long as he isn't
captured and killed zelensky will in
effect be the president of ukraine for
some time to come now um whereas putin's
position has been
challenged by this
i i think you need to know
an awful lot more about what's going on
amongst the russian elite to be to be
sure i don't want i mean the russian
population as far as we can tell is is
broadly supported because what do they
know i mean they're told
on the russian media um
that they don't hear the alternative
voices it's extraordinary how many brave
people have been who have spoken out but
still he said this isn't going to be a
popular movement i think it'll be
worries amongst the russian elite
about the act the total isolation of
their country and the economic hurt
that's coming the sanctions are far more
severe than i expected i think most
people expected
i'm sure the russians expected and
though they've got a war chest it's not
all not all of that's doing them much
good at the moment so i think the
um the problems that putin faces
over the long term are are quite serious
it would be foolish to predict um the
the that he he'll go tomorrow or
uh weeks or day or months or whatever i
just think his position uh is going to
be hard to recover for
from uh
what is this uh
which you said a staggering misjudgment
that he's made
so
but we have to see
dmitry do you think a kremlin coup is a
possibility
look i think it's uh not very likely but
the chance of it is no longer zero if
you had asked me two three weeks ago
what is the likelihood that putin would
be ousted in sort of a palace coup i
would tell you that it was zero
today it's no longer that and i think it
is precisely because the sanctions have
been so severe
and the diplomatic isolation which also
cannot be underestimated uh is rapidly
turning russia into a north korean type
of pariah state
so
when you look at the elites particularly
the the military and intel services
people that have enriched themselves
over decades that have uh through their
families bought properties and
yachts and and other luxuries in the
west and they're now realizing they're
in danger of losing it all and also
realizing most importantly that those
sanctions are not getting removed as
long as putin is in power no matter what
happens in ukraine even if putin manages
to achieve some sort of rapid victory
there
those sanctions are there to stay russia
will remain isolated economically and
diplomatically for years to come if this
man is still in power and i think it's
not out of their own possibilities small
chance very small chance but not zero
that someone particularly in the
silvikey sort of hardliner movement
there will say the old man has made a
drastic mistake we've had enough it's
time for him to step aside
lawrence and dimitri thank you so much
for joining spectator tv
it took a few weeks but much of the
world has fast come together in its
response to putin's invasion
europe the united states and countries
in asia have punished his regime with
sanctions targeting russia's central
bank the rich oligarchs who surround
putin and even russia's sports teams but
is this enough bill browder was once the
largest foreign investor in russia but
became a sanctions campaigner after
exposing corruption in the country his
lawyer sergey magnetsky died in a
russian jail in 2009 after he was
arrested by russian authorities
bill now heads up the global magnetsky
justice campaign
bill thank you so much for joining
spectator tv now you said earlier this
week that you've spent 10 years banging
on closed doors are you now satisfied
with the sanctions that have been
imposed on russia do you think they go
far enough
well i mean we're in a completely sea
change moment
um
in the last week versus the last 10
years in terms of
how
governments and officials and law
enforcement view uh russian oligarchs
now
everybody has kind of woken up to the
fact that these people
for the most part are
are part of the putin international
financial system and if you want to stop
putin you've got to go after the
oligarchs so am i satisfied
um no i'm not satisfied i think a lot
more needs to be done but i'm but i'm
impressed that we've come this far
compared to where we were before um it's
a sea change and the fact that you would
now have you know real um high value
targets on various sanctions list is
something i would have never expected
our russia correspondent owen matthews
has said that we should make sure that
these sanctions target kremlin insiders
rather than ordinary russian people
how punishing are the existing measures
in terms of both groups
well the um there are so there are two
basic set of sanctions there are what i
would call
um
country sanctions and these would be
sanctions against the central bank of
russia against the banking system
against various state-owned banks and
companies
and then there are targeted sanctions
and these are the sanctions against the
oligarchs and the sanctions that are
against the central bank and against
various other banks have led to a
collapse of the ruble it's led to
um
insufficient foreign exchange reserve so
people can't take money out of the bank
and that affects every person and uh and
there's going to be widespread
pain as a result of that which
uh
i i think
the russian people
you know in a certain way they're just
as much victims of vladimir putin as we
are
uh
the oligarch sanctions on the other hand
are extremely
nice because they
are very targeted they go directly to
putin's personal financial interests and
they don't affect anybody else
if we had had a perfect world we could
have done these oligarch sanctions
before putin invaded
and
my theory always was that that because
it's because he he never expected any
sanctions if we had been serious
beforehand he might have done a
different set of calculations
but now we're in this world where
um he has invaded
and we kind of have to throw everything
we have at him
uh in a previous segment on spectator tv
this week we spoke about the possibility
of a palace coup inside the kremlin
dmitry alperovitch told us that he
thinks it remains unlikely but is
certainly a possibility do you think
these sanctions will change the
oligarchs opinion of putin
uh unfortunately i think that there's a
zero percent chance of a palace coup
uh as attractive uh uh
uh an alternative as that may be uh the
reason for that is that the sanctions
the oligarchs don't have
any political power vladimir putin
doesn't listen to them
and at any moment
any of these oligarchs could be arrested
have their money taken away and they
could be killed and so they're there
at the pleasure of vladimir putin and
can be destroyed with one snap of the
fingers and so they're not going to do
anything they're scared they're scared
to death literally scared to death and
um uh it's just not going to happen
so do you think we need to go further on
sanctions now and if so where would you
target them do you double down on the
oligarchs who are already being hit or
do you broaden these sanctions out
well in my opinion we're just starting
this whole oligarch sanction process
there's less than 10 people
10 high-value oligarchs on the u.s
eu and uk list oftentimes they're
different oligarchs on different
different lists
i think the lists need to be coordinated
first of all and the lists then need to
be expanded so 50 or 100 oligarchs are
sanctioned if that were to happen i
think we would see
a real um you know that would be a real
um
punch in the face of vladimir putin and
then he'd have to figure out you know
how does he how does he deal with that
because all that money that offshore
money um his money that he would then
need to be and that's money he'd
probably need to draw on as all of his
other resources are drying up and from
your perspective what is the ultimate
goal of these sanctions is it to punish
putin to pressure him to de-escalate
to rid europe of its dependency on
russian energy altogether
well
there would have been different goals at
different times if we had done this
in advance of him invading if we'd done
it properly which we didn't do
um it might have been to deter him from
invading
now that he has invaded vladimir putin
doesn't have a reverse gear
and therefore the purpose of these
sanctions
on on a wide scale is to deplete his
resources by freezing the central bank
reserves he can't use those to fund his
war
uh by uh sanctioning the oligarchs he
can't use that offshore money to fund
his war
and the hope is that the war is very
expensive
that his resources are depleted
that much much less money is flowing to
russia
and that eventually um with a with a
spirited fight by the ukrainians he just
doesn't have the resources to go further
and we should be very conscious of the
fact that
if if he if he succeeds in ukraine he's
not stopping there that's not the end of
his adventure
he would then go and challenge us on a
nato border and so everything we're
doing right now is to try to
stop him from getting that far
trying to help the ukrainians in any way
we can
and try to deplete his resources
bill last question you've been meeting
with governments across europe for the
last decade do you now get the sense
that there's a fundamental change in
their approach to russia and if so how
long do you think it will last
i think there's absolutely a fundamental
change i think it's permanent
uh vladimir putin if all it takes is
is you know a few more days of watching
what he's doing on television and
there's no way that he can be forgiven
for what he's done
and uh i think that that as time goes on
these sanctions will be
tougher and tougher because he's going
to provoke
all of us into wanting tougher and
tougher sanctions
bill thanks so much for joining
spectator tv
what's happening on the ground in
ukraine our deputy editor freddie gray
has been in la viv in the west of the
country for the last few days and he
joins the show now
you're joining us from live in western
ukraine you've been out there for
several days now and you wrote about
what you're witnessing for this week's
magazine what is it like in the city
uh well it's very very tense um the
people are very tense uh but it's not uh
under any uh
you know any clear or obvious threat
um
there are air sirens that go off quite
regularly and you're sort of shepherded
down into an air shelter
but i haven't heard any uh bombs or
explosions
um and i think the sort of general view
is this is the last place that putin
will try to take on it's a very western
city
uh the people here i mean ukrainians
will tell you everywhere that they are
they are um
you know that they are so patriotic but
also i think this is really a sort of
capital of nationalism for ukraine
in your piece for the magazine freddie
you write that you go into a hipster
cafe and you meet somebody who's making
molotov cocktails and when you ask if
they work they reply that they worked in
2014.
does this conflict feel new and
surprising to the people that you're
meeting or is there a sense that it
wasn't so long ago that they were having
to take similar action
uh no there is i mean there were some
military strikes uh some strikes against
military targets i should say
uh against uh
near near
very early on i think the russians tried
to take out some places there
um
quite successfully i think
uh and there is no
sense of um
i mean the people are not calm because
they are a lot of them have come from
kiev
uh a lot of them are uh
worried people sort of cry when you talk
to them they're very emotional but very
brave as everyone says that's very true
uh but they are also also a lot of them
are scared and emotional so it's it's a
very tense atmosphere
uh but there's there's no um
an indication of sort of
in the uk almost all of the footage that
we're seeing is of the russian forces
being beaten it's what people want to
see but there's also a concern that it's
self-selective as they are clearly
making some advances into ukraine how do
the ukrainian people feel about the
state of affairs right now do they feel
like they're winning
yes very much well certainly they all
say that they are winning a lot and
they're very very keen to say it uh they
love sharing videos of sort of
ukrainians uh
uh
crowing as they look at sort of blown up
tanks and things like that
um and they they are all on a kind of as
i've tried to say in the diary they're
all on this sort of
pr drive uh for the country it's a
mobilized war effort so
uh everybody talked to from quite quite
high level officials down to people you
just talked on the street they all give
you the same messages it's like they're
all on
on message uh and the messages we're
gonna win this war you have to help
you met with one retired general he said
that ukraine needs more military
assistance from the west air defense and
anti-tank kit have you seen any
shipments of western shipments of arms
coming into ukraine through the city
no no i have not uh but it is it's not
just uh him several
people we've spoken to a couple of
officials have said they sort of present
you with a shopping list of what they
want and they expect you as the western
journalist to take this to your
government
and
make the order for them
but
yeah and they're quite specific you know
they they
well the numbers vary um and some some
of the numbers requested are
extraordinary but they want you know
several thousand uh of a certain type of
gun uh as many drones from turkey as
they can get
they're very keen on the british
anti-tank
missiles as has been reported quite a
lot
in terms of a very different kind of
weaponry you write in your piece about
meeting somebody and what you describe
as a hipster cafe who's making
molotov cocktails and when you ask if
they work
they replied that they did in 2014. is
there any sense that this conflict
doesn't feel completely surprising to
people in ukraine that this is in recent
memory that they were having to take
similar action or are the majority
people that you're meeting completely
baffled by what's happened over the past
week
um i think they're they're surprised but
uh ukraine is sort of famously
fatalistic
and they are very
uh aware of the the russian threat
particularly here
um it was quite amusing at that uh
hipster
brewery because uh there was it was a
sort of pr drive really uh and i think
they maybe released it as a kind of
press statement
uh you know there's a pr stunt to say
we're developing this beer but we're
actually going to make molds off
cocktails i think not to say that they
don't sincerely mean to do it as well
but they were hoping to get publicity
for it and then they kind of realized
that was actually maybe a bit of a
really stupid thing to do
because they could be a target now uh as
a result so they looked a little bit
anxious but they were uh
they were
this is not to be cynical about them
trying never to be cynical uh in these
situations because they are uh they are
serious about what they want to do and
if and as i said to one of them i said
do they work and i may have sounded a
little skeptical by mistake and he was
very adamant that they do and they had
done in 2014.
and then he showed me to go back to the
social media point and then he showed me
uh pointed me in the direction of a
video which again several people have
pointed me in the direction of of a
a woman throwing
a petrol bomb onto the treads of a tank
uh just as she drives past in the car
and that's the kind of heroism they want
it's a sort of interference spirit
wow
uh you say in your piece that support
for president zielinski is inspiring uh
he wasn't a particularly popular leader
before this crisis what are people in
lev saying about him now
well they are uh they are some of them
sort of express surprise at how great
he's been and i think they are quite
pleased that the international support
that he's generating uh and uh
one one source said to me uh the the
real clown
uh is poroshenko the the former
president who was a businessman and of
course zielinski was a was a comedian
before so he's saying you know it's it's
poroshenko that's the idiot that is the
sort of fool now because
he's been doing sort of publicity stunts
with holding a rifle and swearing
legions and lots of stuff whereas the
feeling is that
is having a very very good war um but as
i say you have to not take everything
with a pinch of salt so much but you
have to be aware that these guys are
sort of on a wall footing so they're not
going to say anything that they think a
western journalist will construe as
doubt
or uh fear or was clear they don't mind
missing but doubts also that they don't
want us to convey the wrong message
freddie i know you've also been to the
border where you're witnessing people
trying to pass from ukraine into poland
i imagine those are some very difficult
very upsetting scenes
it was it was a pretty depressing scene
yes there was a there was kind of
crossing over from poland there was this
enormously long line
of migrants
uh north african migrants um who
apparently have come from the east
of ukraine they got there pretty quickly
considering this was only day three or
four of the conflict
and they were standing around they said
they'd been there for days
and it was quite i mean uh funny and
tragic at the same time there was this
chap just came up to me and said um
uh is this moldova and he was pointing
at the um the polish border
uh and i had to tell him uh that no
poland uh but he didn't seem too much to
mind that much but he then just trotted
back to his queue
and they all look very bored and quite
scared
yeah
yeah um freddie last question in your
time in la vie what have you been most
surprised by or what have you been there
surprised to see
um
i suppose i've been surprised by
uh
you know the passion i mean i always you
know
one reads a lot about the passion but
because you know one tends journalist
tends to try and be cynical or whatever
you kind of think i must be hyped but
it's not
they're all very very committed
uh and it's kind of it's inspiring but
it's also pretty frightening because you
realize how serious they are about this
and how serious this war could get uh
very quickly
freddie thanks for taking the time stay
safe
in his column for the magazine this week
douglas murray writes about the
right-wing fringe who are supporting
vladimir putin saying he's an antidote
to the west's woke culture to explain
douglas joins me now
douglas thanks so much for joining
spectator tv this week you write in your
column for the magazine that the fringes
of the american right are getting
vladimir putin all wrong can you explain
yes it's not just the american rights i
say parts of the european right and and
even perhaps you could say parts of the
british right have for years um
taken a sort of contrarian view about
putin you know
for years the cold warriors and their
descendants
thought one thing which was you know
putin was an aggressor he was a
strategic threat
and that russia under him uh was going
to remain some kind of challenge to the
west uh but all the time a new
generation was coming along and i don't
just mean age-wise i mean inevitably a
generation that grew up after the cold
war might be more susceptible to to this
view but but older people as well took a
different view which was among other
things that vladimir putin
presented a sort of um
counterweight or counterbalance to some
of the worst madnesses in our own
society i give examples in the piece uh
not least from uh some american
congresswoman which is perhaps most
alarming um but others as well who said
things like well you know
there was a guest on steve bannon's
podcast recently who said who said well
you know in russia they don't they don't
have any problem knowing which bathroom
to use
that sort of thing that because our own
societies were going mad with the sort
of woke stuff that somehow a society
which didn't have any truck with any of
that or even the most basic rights for
lgbt people for instance uh acted as a
sort of admirable counterweight and in
time this this i think has grown and i
show a little bit of how that has
happened uh in the media in politics and
elsewhere where uh where this this
strange new sort of interpretation of
vladimir putin originated and from there
grew
and douglas to flag up some other
examples in your column this was very
obvious at the far right america first
political action conference last month
where attendees were actually chanting
putin putin putin
how did any part of the american right
get to that state
well this this it should be said is an
incredibly fringe part of the american
right it's led by an exceptionally
unpleasant little anti-semite called
fuentes and he he he's one of a
generation of works described as sort of
people who've grown up online and who
think of themselves or described as sort
of edge lords these are really pathetic
people who who like to sort of
play with the dark stuff you might say
play with the things you're not meant to
play around with there are people on the
left who do the same thing you know who
sort of i've written about this in the
past who sort of um
play around with stalinism and other
things knowing how dangerous it is
knowing how unpleasant and upsetting it
is but it's slightly reveling in it and
there has emerged also of a tiny segment
but
a significant thing to note on the
american right which does the same thing
which is for instance as fuentos himself
is sort of into holocaust minimization
if not full holocaust denial uh
holocaust joking certainly a sort of um
all sorts of spreading of ugly
anti-semitic conspiracy theories and
more and one of their main things
they've treated themselves to in this
sort of quasi-sexual thrill which as i
say in the piece is possibly because
they know no other type of sexual thrill
this type of person sort of treated
themselves to um to admiring putin
knowing that this brings condemnation
down on them to some extent but rather
reveling in it so yes at this ugly ugly
uh far-right gathering which
unbelievably the idiot congresswoman
marjorie taylor-green actually spoke to
spoke at
she said she didn't hear the chance of
putin putin putin which happened just
before she came on and things like this
they sort of burst out with their
enthusiasm for putin i think among other
things these people do it i mean it's
not worth lingering over them because
they're not a significant political
force but i think it's a sort of example
of something people who who think our
societies are so decadent that that we
should admire the strong man in the
kremlin of course there are so many
things that are wrong with this
not the least of which is that they take
vladimir putin at his own estimation of
himself like they take uh there's
another one that goes around a lot
online which is a sort of comparison of
the cia recruitment video which i
actually wrote about recently in the
spectator it was
rather ridiculous intersectionalist
recruitment campaign they compare that
sort of thing and the sort of you know
um diversity higher american armed
forces campaigns and they stick that
alongside the recruitment ads for the
russian military where you see these
sort of tough robot looking you know
macho guys and they
the these people on the right in america
europe and elsewhere have sort of taken
this estimate
of the kremlins about itself for
themselves as well
and as i say in the pieces i mean it's
very interesting because
yes exactly they've basically fallen for
a form of russian propaganda which is we
are tough you are weak we are strong
uh you are
uh you know into all of this sort of
woke nonsense and
as i say it it should be kind of
obvious to any thinking conservative
that that you can be simultaneously
aware that your own society is going
kind of mad
and also not as a result look for refuge
in a far madder man sitting in isolation
in the kremlin and ordering the invasion
of neighboring countries
douglas there's a louis theroux
documentary which looks at this part of
america's far right and it's suggested
in the documentary that
this
that this group of people has have its
roots in an online culture twitter
youtube tick tock and that these very
outrageous comments that they're making
like those about putin
are often designed to be trolling rather
than serious
i'm curious as to what you make of that
and i would also put into context that
you know of all the times to talk about
taking people at their word um a lot of
the commentary got what vladimir putin
decided to do over this past week very
very wrong not taking him at his word
not to say that a dictator who
theoretically can you know have his paw
prints on nuclear weapons is the same as
some guy sitting in their mother's
basement you know scrolling along on
tick-tock
but i think we are going to be
asking
increasingly what it means to take
people at their word and um
in in in this situation
how seriously should we be taking these
trolls are they trolls or do they really
mean what they say
uh well that that this is a very
interesting point um by the way i i
would dispute what through i'm great
admirer of through but i've disputed
slightly because actually on the
american right there has has
historically always been a niche but
interesting movement that has taken a
similar view that has said you know
effectively that russia or back in the
day even in the 40s and 50s and 60s
there were some figures on the fringe of
the far right in america who believed
that the soviets were effectively a
natural ally
by the way i mean again you see little
bits of this in the residue of
these movements today the idea is for
instance i mean
absolutely unfathomably stupid thing to
believe under the soviet regime which
was exceptionally anti-clerical but you
see it in the regime today
in the um in some of this response today
the inheritors of this movement who
think that
who think that vladimir putin is for
instance the devout and entirely
non-cynical supporter of the orthodox
church and believer that he occasionally
puts himself out to be i mean how naive
and illiterate historically and
currently you need to be to believe that
vladimir putin's cloaking himself from
the orthodox church is a is a wholly
truthful and fulsome uh uh defense of
christendom is amazing and as i've said
in the past week a number of times uh if
you believe that vladimir putin is the
sort of bulwark the defender of
christendom then you would have to ask
why he's using islamists and indeed
jihadist groups from chechnya to roll in
shouting allahu akbar and going and
murdering orthodox christians in the
ukraine but let's let's pass over that
for a second the the
the more important point in a way is
what you're leading me to is of course
this isn't just about a fringe
because these days in american politics
as in all of our politics there is a
melding point of fringes and the
mainstream
now the most obvious and troubling
example in the past week were the
comments made by former president donald
trump who is of course not at all a
fringe figure
than our last president of the united
states and may well be running to be the
next one his comments on uh on
putin and his invasion of ukraine
i wouldn't say that they are remotely
similar to what these fringe far-right
groups have done but they drink
somewhere from the same well an
admiration of his strength an admiration
of putin's intelligence you know um
i thought that one of the reprehensible
aspects of the trump uh comments that he
that he said not only how clever the the
invasion was in the way in which putin
did it that's of course not to endorse
it and trump has has also condemned it
but trump made his reference the fact
it's so clever of him to have sent in
these peacekeeping forces you know
they're the strongest peacekeeping
forces i've ever seen it's it that's
that's a little bit more than uh
an admiration for a tactical uh a
tactical adversary
that's a sort of admiration for this
tactic
and as i say that's that's not that's
not someone on the fringes social media
may have tried to push donald trump to
the fringes but he's not on the fringes
and i think that there is this there is
this sort of
continuous line on the right
where this temptation to see as i say
because of the deracination of our own
institutions
because of some of the idiocies which
we've well rehearsed on this show before
some of the idiocies in our own society
we overestimate and indeed in some
people's cases positively salivate over
the fact that certain other regimes
particularly dictatorship like that of
vladimir putin doesn't have any of these
problems and can treat themselves to
being more serious in the world as i say
i think it's a massive moral error it's
a strategic error and it also simply
falls for the kremlin's own estimation
of itself
douglas thanks for joining me
and finally i'm joined by james forsyth
and katie balls to give us the latest
from westminster
katie james thanks so much for joining
spectator tv james first what do you
make of the government's response to the
russian invasion of ukraine over the
past week
i think a lot of the strategic decisions
that the uk took have been
vindicated by events i think one of the
reasons why
the uh russian advance in ukraine has
slowed is in part because
of the uk's decision to
send lethal aid to the ukrainian forces
before this conflict began it is
remarkable to think that six weeks ago
uh london didn't even dare ask berlin
for fear of refusal whether it could fly
weapons to kiev over german airspace
yet you now see 20 countries including
germany itself sending lethal aid to the
ukrainians you know there is a question
of how much more benefit that would have
happened if that if that aid had been
sent before the conflict began
i think where the uk government is
having a problem is that the sanctions
process on individuals within the uk it
is just not working um you talk to
people in government and there is
despair about
how uh slow-going it is and uh there is
a sense of things that's not not going
to get better on that front anytime soon
i think that is going to
begin to cause some serious political
embarrassment for the government and
james on that point some are saying that
because the government has been slow to
sanction russian oligarchs in particular
this has enabled lots of them to leave
the country and now they're looking to
ditch their assets is that going to be a
political problem let alone a
geopolitical problem
yeah i think there is clearly there is
clearly an awkwardness which is on
things like swift for example you know
the uk is out front very forward leaning
but in terms of sanctions on individuals
the uk is turning into a laggard and it
is going to become embarrassing as you
see lots of people close to vladimir
putin essentially selling up and leaving
london
and taking the cash out of the country
katie it was maybe a month ago that
boris johnson's premiership look looked
like it was in a perilous position now
we'd assume it's not at least not
immediately what is the mood amongst
those who wanted to see boris johnson go
have they had a change of heart
i think there is a clear sense that now
is not the time um i've spoken to
various mps who are considering putting
letters in some who had and i think
there was actually unity on the point
that
no one really i'm yet to speak to anyone
in the tory party who thinks that now is
the time for a leadership contest or
even to push towards a confidence vote i
think even perhaps if you were to have
the police announce a fixed penalty
notice for the prime minister in the
coming days i would now be skeptical
that would lead to a confidence vote and
i don't think it means that boris
johnson's position is rosy i mean i
think that's
in a way we're in a very somber time if
you think about the situation in ukraine
russia's invasion and but i think that
uh
for the next you know few months this is
just not something which is at the top
of people's minds and instead there is a
sense that it's a very grave situation
and the best thing that you can have is
unity in the tory party and also i think
a sense of unity across the house you
saw it um when david lammy the shadow
foreign secretary was speaking this week
he said you know the putin must also
deal the united kingdom and i think that
you're seeing fewer partisan attacks
between the sides i think during the
pandemic you often heard um both labour
and the tories saying they weren't going
to have partisan attacks and then they
would actually just do that and whereas
i think in this situation there is a
more realistic prospect of that
james something that may be on voter's
minds however is the growing cost of
living crisis uh which was set to be bad
before the sanctions hit but now with
the sanctions especially on energy could
really see bills going through
the roof how serious is that effect
going to be and has the government done
enough to prepare people
for what they're about to experience
i think it is going to be very serious
and i don't think the government has
done enough you know in his speech in
poland this week boris johnson had a
line talking about how you know dealing
with this crisis was going to and the
sanctions on russia were going to impose
costs at home
as well and that energy bills would go
up but i think he needs to address
people more directly on this point i'm
very struck by the fact that both uh joe
biden and emmanuel macron have used
their addresses to their voters to speak
directly about this point i think boris
johnson needs to get people ready for
the fact that energy prices and food
prices are going to go up because of
this conflict
and katie last question to you if we are
looking at a very serious cost of living
crisis how is boris johnson ever going
to deliver on his leveling up agenda and
the other promises that he made when he
went into number 10 in the medium to
long term it still feels as if the
conservative party's prospects are a lot
worse than they were a few months ago
yeah there's lots of big questions i
think that have been raised by the
escalating situation in ukraine and
we've already seen for example and james
is talking about this this big shift
across europe so um the germans are
increasing defense spending and i i mean
i think it's quite clear there's going
to be a push for the uk to expand to
expand its defense budget going forward
and you also save a situation where cost
of living is going to get worse even
worse i think than the predictions that
we um had
pre-ukraine and the russian invasion and
inflation could even potentially hit
double figures um so you put all these
things together that's not an easy
situation for any you know governing
party to be in and it makes things like
leveling up harder but i also think this
goes back to james's point which is
effectively if you have a situation
where um the prime minister is able to
level the public and actually not really
um you know present this as a choice so
there is no choice here is this or
actually allowing russia to keep going
where will that ever end and you will
bring people inside but it's going to be
tough and if i were the tories you'd
want to almost bring labour in on some
of these points given that is currently
unity in the house of commons broadly
speaking on ukraine and russia
and i think that if boris johnson starts
to talk about rising prices well kirsten
if he's really going to say he supports
us needs to come in behind him and i
think now would be the time to start
doing that
james and katie thanks for joining me
and that's it for this week once again
we're delighted that canaccord genuity
wealth management is sponsoring the week
in 60 minutes can accord will provide
the expertise you need to build your
wealth with confidence you can visit
candywealth.com to find out more
and if you've enjoyed this episode don't
forget to subscribe to the spectators
youtube channel just click on the
subscribe button at the bottom of this
video and tap the bell icon to make sure
you never miss an episode
thanks for watching and do join us again
next week
[Music]
you